houi rebels in the Red Sea armed
conflict in Gaza skirmishes in South
Lebanon Iran and its proxies are working
tirelessly to strike at the heart of
American and Israeli interests from
lethal attacks on US forces in Jordan to
Precision strikes at Israel the goal is
clear the complete expulsion of American
influence from the Middle East some
lawmakers in the west are now looking
for chinks in the armor to strike back
however Iran has held roughly the same
borders for over 500 years it has fought
nearly all superpowers at their
respective zeniths and live to tell the
tale think of the Romans the Arabs the
Turks the Russians and the British to
name a few quite simply fighting Iran
headon is a terrible idea it could
backfire
disproportionately not only does the
country operate an extensive network of
Shia milit AR proxies but even inside
its own boundaries a conventional
Invasion would be a Herculean task Teran
has constantly demonstrated its ability
to withstand invasions making it almost
impossible to subjugate but why is that
what makes Iran so tough is it just
mountains or is there more to it to find
out we need to dive deep into what makes
the country tick and how it evolved to
its current configuration
we need to look more closely at the
surface because geography reveals the
soul of a
Nation today's video is sponsored by
conflict of Nations a free online
strategy game where you choose a real
country to lead into a modern global
conflict up to 128 other players are
moving their units across the map in
real time so to win you need to form
alliances and construct all types of
units including tanks Jets and
submarines conflict of Nations is a huge
game it can take weeks for a game round
to complete which makes Logistics as
necessary as tactics the key to Victory
is to think ahead and build alliances
what I like most about the game is that
you can play with the same account on
both PC and mobile that convenience sets
it apart from other games using our link
below you will get an exclusive gift
13,000 gold and 1 month of Premium
subscription for free the offer is only
available for 30 days so get started
sooner rather than
[Music]
later Iran is defined by its mountains
its topographic Peaks form the country's
walls and encase its cities with the
most important being the zagas mountains
to the Southwest the zag gently slope
down into Iraq and to the north they
form an almost impassible border with
turkey the only section of the Western
border not guarded by Topography is
protected by the marshes where the
Tigris and Euphrates rivers
converge looking North the alarts
mountains provide another natural border
while a ribbon of lesser Peaks curls
around Iran's East marking the borders
with Afghanistan and
Pakistan the see forms the final wall of
the castle Iran's Coastline stretches
nearly 2,500 km and is split roughly
between the Persian Gulf and the Gulf of
Oman bandar abas Iran's most crucial
Port stands Sentinel Midway along the
straight of Hormuz an artery through
which about a fifth of the world's
petroleum
pulses concurrently the straight of
Hormuz is Iran's Chief geopolitical
Leverage
should tyan decide to make good on its
threat and disrupt the flow of fossil
fuels the global economy would be shaken
to its core this then gives Iran
substantial bargaining power when
negotiating with its
peers however when left at peace the
straight confines Iran to land power
since it lacks a competing Port along
the Gulf of Oman that can rival bander
abas in all geography not only serves as
a boundary but also cradles the majority
of Iran's 90 million citizens enclosed
within its borders the cavier and Luth
deserts form vast Barren plateaus that
cluster the populace within a Highland
belt historically this topographical
anomaly has made Iran incredibly tough
to
subjugate however like so many things in
Iran reality Cuts both ways while the
mountain protect Iran they also contain
it Westward Expansion tends to lead to
conflicts with powerful Empires think of
the Russians the Turks the Arabs and the
Romans before it and when Iran does
somehow manage to expand Westward it
usually grants autonomy to the conquered
territories this strategy is mainly due
to the logistics of mountainous terrain
which makes policing distant regions
both challenging and expensive Ive Jerry
Mander autonomy is a strategy as old as
the Persian Empire which maintained its
culturally diverse territory by granting
self-governance to its vassals and
client
states fast forward to today and we see
a similar pattern Iran's power
projection now relies on a network of
primarily Shia proxy groups each
operating with varying degrees of
Independence while these proxies are not
Direct quests they serve as extensions
of Iranian influence for a deeper dive
into this topic be sure to check out our
previous video where we explore Iran's
use of proxy States in Greater
detail Iran's mountains make fully
assimilating its many diverse cultures
and peoples exceedingly tricky The
Towering Peaks create pockets of
isolation where communities cling to
their unique languages traditions and
identities so while its mountains Shield
Iran from foreign domination they also
complicate the formation of a unified
centralized government ethnic Persians
make up just 55 to 60% of the population
with the rest comprising azer Banis
balois Kurds Arabs turkman and many
others the clustering of these ethnic
groups in specific region
fuels calls for autonomy and separatism
historically Iran has granted autonomy
to these groups but the centralization
of power in Teran led to the corrosion
of their political
freedoms consequently a centralized Iran
has evolved into an authoritarian State
tan must constantly grapple with calls
for autonomy and independence by its
ethnic groups for example during the
Islamic revolution of 1979 Kurds turkman
and Arabs sought to secede from Iran
while azer Banis aimed for more
self-governance although these movements
were suppressed they underscored the
ethnic volatility within
Iran now while reviewing these internal
mechanisms one disclaimer needs
explaining in a more compassionate World
there wouldn't be a need to examine ways
to un one another but geopolitics is
precisely like that exploiting a
country's multiethnic population may be
morally questionable but it is a
weakness nonetheless and there are those
who have no problems getting their hands
dirty policy makers study plan and act
on such exploits so regardless of morals
the fact remains that ethnic tensions
Drive much of Iran's foreign policy many
of Iran's minority groups share deep
running ties with their kin
abroad azer Banis in the Northwest share
close cultural and linguistic ties with
azerbajan the Kurds have connections
with Kurdish populations in Iraq and
turkey to the South roughly 1.6 million
Arabs who predominantly inhabit Iran's
oil Rich province of kistan share ties
with various Arab communities across the
Middle East
meanwhile in the Southeast the bosis
have strong ties with their counterparts
in Pakistan with both groups fighting
their respective
overlords these crossb ethnic
solidarities complicate Iran's bilateral
relations with its surroundings tan is
consistently wary of its neighbors
believing they would back separatist
groups aiming for unification
particularly during periods of national
instability
the ever looming threat of breakaway
regions foretells disaster such
disintegration would not only shrink
Iran's territorial size and population
but also severely Dent its tax revenue
moreover the loss of the kastan oil
fields would plunge tan into a financial
Abyss oil is the Cornerstone of Iran's
economy accounting for a staggering 24%
of GDP growth in 2023 three its loss
would be
cataclysmic without its minority regions
Iran would lose its geopolitical Cloud
the rump Persian majority state would
likely be landlocked and stripped of its
mountainous borders leaving it exposed
security wise while this worst case
scenario of Iran's fragmentation may
seem farfetched it has happened numerous
times in history in more recent years
Iran's aders Aries have sought to
exploit its ethnic and religious fault
lines Israel has strengthened its ties
with aeran and shown interest in
supporting aarani separatist movements
within Iran similarly some have linked
Saudi Arabia to efforts aimed at
fomenting Arab separatism in the kistan
province a region with a significant
Arab population that borders Iraq since
Iran is nearly imposs possible to
neutralize from the outside adversaries
like the United States and Israel see
separatism as the only option to
neutralize the threat that is
Iran however while the threat of
balkanization exists Iran's lack of
homogeneity may not be the Achilles heel
its adversaries long for during the Iran
Iraq war Iraqi propaganda emphasized
Iran's ethnic and sectarian divides
portraying the Iranian government as
Persian chauvinist oppressors of
minorities the aim was to stoke ethnic
tensions and separatist sentiments
within Iran Saddam hoped that Iran's
Arab minority particularly in the oil
Rich kastan Province would take up arms
and support the Iraqi invasion they did
not Iraq also supported Kurdish
separatist groups like The Kurdistan
Democratic party and the Patriotic Union
of Kurdistan in their fight against the
Iranian government hoping their
Insurgency would weaken Iran this Ploy
had some success initially it forced the
country to relocate resources to
suppress the Kurdish Rebellion yet
saddam's plan ultimately failed and the
war ground to a
[Music]
stalemate the fabric of society is based
on shared values common goals and
communal experience these attributes
Foster trust cooperation and mutual
support among its
members however sometimes Nations can
achieve the same result by creating the
US versus them narrative this dichotomy
creates a sense of belonging and
solidarity within each group while
fostering separation and sometimes
hostility towards the other group during
the Iran Iraq war Teran heavily pushed
Iranian nationalist rhetoric that put
the war as a fight between Shia and
sunnis it's the reason why saddam's Ploy
failed but to grasp the efficacy of this
strategy a glimpse into history is
warranted in 1501 ismel I was crowned
sha inis heralding the dawn of the
safavid Empire originating from the
region that roughly corresponds to
modern-day azerbajan the new sha went on
on to conquer a vast Empire but Ismael
is seen as the founder of modern Iran
not because he amassed territory but
because he declared 12 Shia Islam as the
state religion of his Empire this
decision unified diverse ethnic and
linguistic groups under one religious
identity and distinguished the safv
dynasty from surrounding Sunni powers
like the Ottoman and mugal
Empires promoting Shia Islam solidified
ismael's control legitimized his Rule
and laid the foundation for modern
Iran's religious and cultural identity
interestingly Isel himself was an ethnic
minority belonging to the azer bani
faction and so did his court and massive
Army which proves the point that
religious unity comes before ethnic
loyalty either way for the first time in
the PO Islamic period all of Iran's
ethnic groups came together in agreement
today Shia Islam Remains the dominant
branch in Iran with 90 to 95% of the
population identifying as such this
religious homogeneity with its shared
beliefs rituals and religious practices
helps Foster a sense of unity among the
various ethnic groups but that's not all
by promoting Shia Islam Teran achieves
not only National unity and social
cohesion but also gains strategic
leverage in places where Shia
communities form a majority so for the
Iranian State Shia Islam lights two
candles with one flame yet Iran is not
entirely Shia pockets of Sunni Muslims
thought the periphery their ideological
beliefs stand in stark contrast to those
of the Shia majority despite attempts at
integration and assimilation many sunnis
view separatism as the only viable path
forward among these dissenting voices
the Sunni balois are the most compelling
faction their cultural and religious
distinctiveness sets them apart from the
Persian Shia majority several baloi
separatist factions are already actively
waging an Insurgency against tan albeit
at a relatively low intensity conversely
Iran may have overplayed its Shia card
in the Years following the Islamic
revolution even government studies show
that Iranians have become less religious
than before when all the noise quiets
down faith is often unappreciated when
it's imposed on people simply put Shia
Islam is steadily losing its cohesive
power if it hasn't already so to keep a
hold on power regardless Tran employs
good old-fashioned brute force it does
not tolerate descent and when Defiance
arises the security apparatus tightens
its grip dissidents are crushed arrested
or sent to the Gallows when Mass
anti-government protests erupted across
Iran in 2022 the largest in nearly four
decades teran's tools of suppression
kicked into full gear State media went
into overdrive portraying protesters in
provinces with large ethnic minorities
as terrorists and separatists to
discredit the movement meanwhile
hundreds of protesters were arrested and
Iranian Security Forces deployed in full
force to brutally crack down on the
demonstrations ultimately despite the
size and scale of the protests Iran was
able to subdue them any foreign-backed
separatist movement would inevitably
face similar constraints when facing
Iran's media apparatus and security
forces it would be an uphill battle from
start to
finish nevertheless those seeking to
harm Iran might consider balkanization
as the only viable strategy short of War
America and Israel for instance see
Iran's ethnic minorities as cracks in
the armor would a foreign backed
separatist proxy conflict truly work
probably not but some lawmakers might
think it's worth the effort
regardless this is also the reason why
the Iranian leadership does not Embrace
democracy wholeheartedly here's the
kicker psychological operations are
rarely ever so apparent the clergy in
power believes that Western Powers
seeking to push Iran toward
disintegration want to package their
AIMS in a virtuous ideology such as
liberal democracy Teran believes that by
embracing liberal ideas its cohesion
would drift apart within a few
Generations without authoritarianism or
theocracy holding it together Iran's
minority regions would likely employ
liberal rights to pursue their own
identities and in time separate from
Iran altogether taken together Iran is
stuck doing the same thing over and over
again this is not a story with a happy
ending Iran must choose one of two pains
the pain of discipline or the pain of
regret I've been your host chivon from
Caspian report if you approve of what we
do please leave a comment and mayhaps
share the video in any case thank you
for your time and S
[Music]
n